have you ever been in an engine that
you'll feel versus no I just that day I
think where am I okay I just wanna meet
you and see you age right you should go
into and every one day and go I just
have to tell you and I've never said
this what I just saw is garbage if you
really look for something that will
destroy your career
I look like doing this is gonna be yummy
I read that husband a dime at me Bonjour
guys oh yeah so guys your friendship
impunity is the highlight of the film
our friendship in real life is the
highlight of our lives
wonderful I'm not leavin tonight I was
gonna say I you like song power perfect
we are we are we are in fact Luke got
very upset with me because he couldn't
find me last night
good luck about 20 text messages lately
and I didn't decide my phone died and I
got I was actually very it was it
actually really made me proud that Luke
cared so much and he's like where are
you I need you now what I didn't realize
was Tuesday's is a mermaid night oh
that's my viewing party night when it's
just a party of one
oh yeah so son is off Arielle is on hair
brushes in hand also depending on what
you want to do it's your call so better
dinglehopper go ever and a half yeah and
yeah yes I'm watching and your system I
literally cannot think of any other TV
actors to play your well was like which
there's a lot guys before and say thank
you so much it was originally actually
Chris Pratt and Jonah help and what
happened was scheduling so Luke and I
chose yeah really like you know what all
right we can do it my limit mint state
thank you I think about hundreds I drove
on Sadie's also that says one thing Phil
bill bill is the greatest gonna pain
like her he really is the greatest human
being and director
sort of like kind of checks every night
many people like him know he makes
everybody
and the Gaston has a very short temper
and what's many things bring out the
rage any new loop in me night traffic
get you any annoying
um actually really bad drivers yeah
drives me crazy I come bearing drive
being the college my mother is another
one because she's from the backseat
cheese cheese oh I think I actually like
the special effects machine to do no no
seriously um and also been woken from
the deep sleep oh yeah crying and that's
not nice that happened in cash
I think this restroom that we're in
right now is a little of my red my
bedroom oh and so and Josh you recently
and came to London and all the UK effort
and and you went to - castle whatever
clothes have you had words with Dan
students about that now as a matter of
fact they did just two nights ago
oh why should you know I said first off
you destroyed Mead the Christmas of
whenever Matthew Crawley said goodbye to
the cast of Downton Abbey that was
strike number one strike number two he's
driving all the way to Highclere Castle
and it being closed I don't want to see
strike number three because it'll end
with our friendship coming to an end I
you said he was scared you know he is
scared but he hides it really well
because he has no soul Luke retain top
ten in grammars next year's amendment
how do you think that's on with handle
number two comes on the top of my hate
hand number one in our climbers back
dressed man coming I'm on my mind the
cup country sure thank you I'm gonna
share my world with you
will you yeah alright and that I'm
Beyonce yeah I'm gonna break it in half
a year half of my game a glamour award
Josh you have two daughters are you
excited that they have role models such
as Emma Watson who's really passionate
about feminism is that just something
really great but we have one in life it
is I mean I think that it
it's amazing that they have role models
like Emma it's amazing that they have
you know movies like this because Beauty
and the Beast the animated version was a
definitive classic for us growing on and
I feel like in many ways this has the
opportunity to be their definitive
version of this tale as old as time to
be corny you know it's one of these
things where I feel like with Cinderella
the recent one that's their version
Jungle Book
that was their version so to be a part
of that traditional of adapting these
films and making those the iconic lassic
for that generation I love that I can
share that with the girls and I love
that I can work with somebody as
incredibly smart bright and proactive as
Emma Watson and I'm obviously thank you
so much dying but make this tick tock
keep sight